ah mais tu es sérieux tu vas chanter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour qu'on l'appelle maman celui-ci
c'est pour toutes les béliers
pour toutes les winnies
elle est en seconde dans un lycée de
banlieue sort avec un mec de son
quartier depuis peu il est comme elle
aime c'est-à-dire un peu plus vieux il a
l'air amoureux ils ont tout pour être
heureux elle a jamais fait elle a tenté
juste le bon gars
donc ça va swinguer elle enlève son
temps il
[Musique]
réussites
elle a découvert qu'en fait il est fait
un résultat elle je vois ton tour
elle n'est pas d'accord elle voit les
choses autrement elle dit qu'elle se
sent prête pourquoi on appelle maman
celui-ci c'est pour toutes les Aurélie
pour
toutes les nuits je peux te dire que
toute ta vie elle sera elle se
rappellera le jour où elle annonçant
tous à sa mère et son papa et là dans sa
qu'elle était enceinte de 3 mois et ne
s'attendait pas à ce qu'il sautent de
toi mais elle espérait quand même plus
bonne fois je vois qu'ils ont pétillant
et la galère commence à Aurélie n'a que
16 ans et elle attend un enfant avec ses
parents lui conseillère fortement elle
n'est pas d'accord elle voit les choses
autrement elle dit que tu sens prête
pour toi la peine maman celui-ci c'est
pour toutes les homélies
[Musique]
elle aura tout essayé comme on dit dans
les quartiers elle s'est saignée pour
trouver quelqu'un qui veut bien avancer
de ne pas lâcher la personne lui a
enseigner on a tous connu une fille dans
le cadeau et là le nouveau qui grossesse
est synonyme de délice faut jeter par
ses amis mais surtout sa famille c'est
censé dire que ça va toujours
est-ce que vous êtes chaud ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la dernière
aurélie n'a que 16 ans et elle attend un
enfant ses amis et ses parents lui
conseillent avant
elle va les choses autrement elle dit
qu'elle se sent prête pour la peine
maman celui-ci c'est pour toutes les
Aurélie
[Musique]
pour doutez
Colonel Reyel
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
tu seras vendredi
tu seras vendredi au Christophe club de
Arras et samedi tu seras Pierrefitte sur
scène pour la journée de la solidarité
pour les sinistrés de la tempête Fiona
et on peut l'applaudir parce que c'est
un tube je te jure je suis fou de ce
sang